being able to get a lead and be able to
connect with a cyber security
professional means that you have
phenomenal personality skills because
you're able to uh sell speak
and connect with some of the most
skeptical people in the world
um professionals white collar
professionals and that's why i love
cyber security marketing
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i'm with joel israel the
founder and ceo of wadi digital the
world's leading tech marketing agency
and scifluencer the only b2b tech
influencer marketing platform
ul is also the founder and host of the
youtube channel israel unfiltered a
platform for israeli news and culture ul
is passionate about sales linkedin and
entrepreneurship and if you want to see
passion watch this episode
israel welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for joining me today
how are you i'm doing awesome is 20
minutes gonna be enough
definitely not definitely not but we're
gonna try to crunch it in here to fit
the format and if not i'm just gonna
take up the whole night so thank you
very much for joining me and y'all
you're doing something that's so
fascinating to me you're taking a you
know a passion of mine which is cyber
security and you're putting it together
with something i know very little about
which is marketing and it's also
something that is not really trivial uh
you know when you're thinking about you
know what is the you know biggest
connection to cyber security so i'm
excited to both understand your journey
into this intersection of cyber and
marketing and also talk about sci
fluence talk about wadi digital and and
how you're building you know your own
career and your own expertise through
these domains so you all thank you very
much for being here
uh yeah my pleasure thanks again for
having me i mean intro to kind of you
know like everything else things kind of
happen naturally and you kind of stumble
your way into things in a way um that's
like probably 75 percent true the other
25 true as i saw an opportunity at
something that i was excellent at and i
executed very hard um but i mean i've
always had a good brain for marketing
and media i understand how to grab
attention how to give attention i'm a
fantastic communicator in order i'm very
good at selecting what words to use when
which made me a really good ad
copywriter
um so i started actually working for a
friend of mine for 30 shekels an hour at
night doing google ads like like
eight years ago nine years ago and
that's how i kind of got into
advertising but originally i was
introduced to twitter in 2009 by my
friend hilo fold who's very well known
in israel and the tech scene in general
telling me i had to get on twitter then
and i did and uh like then i was
studying my mba barlow university i got
barilon on twitter they ended up giving
me a scholarship
and uh so that went well and then uh i
don't know i don't use twitter now i i
could see it it's like it's a cesspool
of the worst people in the world wait
wait i want to make sure i understood
this you all you got a scholarship to
borrow on through twitter
through leveraging twitter
i built it for them okay so i was like
hill was like yeah you know twitter was
like new then he's like dude you gotta
get on twitter blah blah blah i'm like i
don't know who you are and how did i end
up in this coffee shop where you're
buying me coffee he convinced me to come
meet him and bait chamesh uh you know as
far as i know could have been a predator
he's the sweetest man he really excel
people and uh so i wanted to test it out
so i did it with uh i created my own
twitter and better then i didn't went
for briarland business school and i
helped them attract international
students and then
they told me they succeeded and so they
ended up giving me i was studying there
at the same time so they actually
deducted my com my uh tuition
it's like uh incredible anyway so after
that yeah i went back to philly then and
that was 2009. um and then i was kind of
doing it on the side facebook mostly
organic and
for local businesses not really much
twitter no one knew what it was uh
facebook was fresh then i was introduced
to ads i saw what you can do with ads i
saw the dashboard and i had a finance
background so i love those numbers and i
love looking at all that data and then i
understood that i actually get to
manipulate the actual numbers i'm
actually an active participant i'm not
just analyzing as opposed to what i
studied in finance um and it provided
more room for personality and i was like
oh this is great this is what i'm going
to do i ended up when i made aliyah i
landed with a job in tourism and then at
night i was doing something for google
ads for a friend for 30 shekels an hour
and then um
basically i started to i understood it
and i was like oh i'm going to dominate
in this um and
he um he's a great guy but he was like
dude you're like uh you're a little too
uh a little too much for me uh i ended
up started selling and he wouldn't do
most of the serving he was the expert he
was a google ads whiz
and uh and he would trade me and pay me
30 shekels and i would do it and then i
would start to get more money if i
brought in sales and then i asked to go
at 50 50 with him and he was like dude i
got 10 years experience he was like four
months and he was like no i was like
yeah but i can bring in business i've
already brought in a couple clients i
mean they were small and they weren't
cyber security or anything like that
and he he wasn't having it so then i
just broke off started wadi digital with
no intention of building anything you
know my logos were five or five bucks
and then it just naturally grew and then
when linkedin ads really started to take
off i was doing linkedin ads i was the
first one of the first like i think 20
core advertisers in the world the first
in israel um i was using linkedin lead
generation forums i was among the first
that i was able to get teva
international a lot of big clients and
then i was like hey just like i captured
you on linkedin ads i'm going to help
you use it for acquisition i was always
the leading linkedin advertiser in the
world and i just embraced it and that's
because i actually have a strong
background in linkedin we actually took
a course in college in 2006 about
linkedin when it was just a recruitment
platform when i was studying finance
underground it was just a recruitment
platform it was basically your cv that's
it there was it was just like it was a
cv there was no posting there was no
news feed the home screen was your
profile
uh it was a hundred percent for
recruitment like and we had a whole
thing about it because they were trying
to help you get employment and it was
like this development it was really you
know it was a very good business school
i went to fox school of business at
temple university in philly where i'm
from
um so i had that whole background and i
loved the platform um and i loved it and
i love business i love networking with
people and i mean now linkedin is really
what i it's the platform i really love
because it's kind of like everything on
facebook without everything that you
hate right so my in-laws aren't there my
parents aren't there your cat's videos
aren't there your politics aren't there
your opinion on vaccines or mass or
coronavirus and that is not there it's
just positive productivity business
networking people that have the same
mindset as me or the only thing i think
i think about this a lot lately the one
thing linkedin is missing is blue collar
workers and those are the real people
that actually move our economy keep the
lights on the water running and
everything else a lot of people that we
take for granted um and those are
probably the most important and
fascinating personalities and they're
probably missing the most um but i would
take out wales topic and so that's how i
kind of got the linkedin ads and then
actually being in israel i went because
cyber security started to network into
that way and just started throwing
events called linkedin local tel aviv
where we'd all get together in tel aviv
talk about people we know on linkedin
that we never met in person we would
meet and i would talk about like
linkedin tactics sometimes they're
bringing guest speakers from dale
carnegie israel and you know uh bro hill
full on so i brought you know all kind
of great marketers and um i'm actually
planning one now in the metaverse in the
first week of february uh
you don't need a vr set it's kind of
like doom you can use like your your
computer um and because we have a client
that's doing events in the metaverse and
so we're using them to and help promote
them for cyber marketers but more on
that next week
but they're so yeah i just naturally
networked my way in there but then i
also fell in love with cyber security
because i love cyber security
professionals i don't mean the marketers
i mean the cyber security people that
they target now one i have an advantage
of american who worked in morgan stanley
and xerox and philly i understand how
the i understand what the businesses
look like who goes to a conference room
who shows up to what meetings i
understand how to target who the
influencers and decision makers are i
know how to map out an enterprise an
organization and i know how to
understand who speaks to whom these are
things that i understand better than
anyone else in israel and even many
people in america themselves because i'm
very i'm able to absorb this information
very well
but uniquely about what i like about
cyber security professionals is that
they're natural skeptics kind of like me
when they hear something they gotta be a
little worried why because everything
that they see that comes by their desk
they're always thinking of how is this a
security threat that's their entire life
whatever it is
your wi-fi your email your username is
your badge being hacked everything
they're entirely cyber security
professionals at these enterprises or
even smvs that is their sole
responsibility so naturally they're
skeptics and i'd like that i was able to
speak to them and being able to get a
lead and be able to connect with a cyber
security professional means that you
have a phenomenal personality skills
because you're able to
uh sell speak
and connect with some of the most
skeptical people in the world
um the professional white collar
professionals and that's why i love
cyber security marketing so i use my
persuasion skills and i don't mean that
negative i mean in a positive way my
communication skills my understanding of
enterprises the needs of cyber security
professionals and my very strong
networking in order to provide
phenomenal results for our cyber
security clients here in israel in order
to reach those enterprises abroad so
they can continue to grow and we can
continue to revolutionize cyber security
and keep the world safe
cyber security
is that a passion of yours is that
something that that requires interest in
order to be good in marketing in it
um interest no um no you need to
understand who you're marketing to
so like if you know what i mean you
don't need to have like a passion or an
interest or things right so like
you know like you don't have to and by
the way i'm uh i don't believe in
following your passion or things like
that i think that's [__] um i think
you should find what you're good at and
bring your passion with it
and that that's and see how you can find
what's the difference what what is what
is the difference there it's in one's
difference but but it's not even your
watch it's huge i don't know michael
what are you passionate about
ten years how old about michael
25 oh my god you're young okay five
years when you were in the before when
you were what were you passionate about
five years ago when you're getting out
of the army were you passionate about
wow behavioral economics okay what are
you doing now you're talking to a
microphone vc
did i mean why are you going to
behavioral economics you know what i
mean i i was passionate about baseball
not playing baseball you know well maybe
would have been a great player no dude
i'm five seven
definitely not seriously also you're
confronted with is it with with the
challenge you're getting in this client
that has to to now be represented by you
in in campaigns and you're gonna have to
think strategically about how to
message that client towards individuals
that are experts that understand what
they're talking about and they're and
potentially can pay a lot of money for
this how do you strategically go about
thinking through how to message if you
don't understand the technology
well you don't first i do understand the
technology because it demonstrated to me
i may not understand it at the scope
that they do but i understand that the
problems the issues and the
vulnerabilities that these enterprises
have and understand the solutions my
cyber security companies my clients my
clients have so i'm able to i am a
strong communicator so i can communicate
to them in a way that they would
understand however that being said i
understand that they're often not
necessarily they're skeptical of ads in
general and i found that especially with
let's say linkedin ads which very top
funnel means that they're never actually
interested in the product at that moment
there's no intent it's not like google
search which is obviously much better in
order if you want to get something to
convert is that i understood is that
they the thing is that the biggest most
important thing in marketing whether
cyber security or not cyber security
even more so is the importance of trust
okay michael i trust you if you
recommend me work with a certain product
software or technology such as we're
using this uh company called riverside
which is what we're recording on here
and you were telling me how great they
are you know and they're still improving
that's awesome great i trust you so
something i'm willing to consider to do
on my podcast my recordings lovely the
same thing with cyber security marketers
even more so so there are certain cyber
security and security professionals that
they follow that people will trust and
they will literally they'll file they'll
follow them blindfolded and so what we
what i've done is since linkedin and
google wasn't enough in order to be able
to get those sales and that trust that i
needed for my for my clients
i decided to build a cyber security
influencer marketing platform called
sciflenzer um and we have dozens of
clients cyber security companies on it
and dozens of height very top tier
influencers and what we're able to do is
they go and they share your content so
instead of me trying to do it via ads or
organically or god forbid just cold
message uh cyber security people they'll
tell you to [__] off and and they'll
share with all of their friends never
talk to this person and you'll probably
have some like lists now like people to
be avoided you'd be surprised if these
people go through i can show you some
reddit threads
but uh what ends up happens is that uh
is that they trust these people they're
gonna share your content and now these
people are have very high integrity of
cyber security professionals mostly csos
north america on our platform they come
in you look at the cyber security
companies content we only share very
good and valuable content if not we
don't let them on the platform we're
extremely picky they go they share that
content onto their socials everything's
trackable and then what they're able to
do is they have to have 50 characters of
their own introducing and saying why
they should read this piece now it comes
off as an organic recommendation from
someone that people in the industry
everyone trust and they would never
share anything they don't stand behind
and they would never say anything that
they really don't honestly believe
because that's the character and that's
the personality of cyber security
professionals which is why i love them
so much and so i've been able to reach
them by the finding the people that they
listen to they're not listening to
linkedin they're not listening to
outreach they're saying [__] you to your
ads they don't care they don't trust
anything so when there isn't a solution
they don't i built the solution the same
thing is that we decided to find out
they're reading cyber security magazines
online they're only trusting other cyber
security professionals so we built
something called cyberintel mag.com it's
a cyber security magazine so we can best
serve our clients eventually we're going
to do all this for ai also too we've
just got to get to a critical mass to
the point where more profitable and then
we're going to obviously take what we've
learned and adapt it to other industries
as ai big data so there's really what
you're doing is you're instead of you
thinking how do i get through to this
person which is wrong you want to say
the question is who do they listen to
and why do they listen to and how can i
get that person to say what i want in
good faith
and then we pursue that aggressively and
through that i've been able to build a
fantastic reputation of how we're able
to deliver for our clients and that no
one else can able to do because we
weren't just looking at another meet or
a me too marketing agency we also do
linkedin we also do google we also b2b
we also do cyber no we do cyber
marketing no one else has the products
that we built we don't have any
competition
we literally don't so therefore it's a
marketplace so it's kind of hard just
like linked in some competition so there
there's the only way it's through us so
even competitors that might be doing
marketing for cyber security companies
they're still using scifilanza for
influencer marketing because we're
getting that demand chain that top
funnel stuff to get them to find out who
you are and coming your website and
begin with and then of course all the
remarketing kicks in there after once
they come to your site i'm able to
retarget them and bring them into the
funnel and that's how you're able to
succeed
incredible
going back to the roots of marketing as
a you know obviously
you know the way you communicate in the
way that you think and strategically
think it's it's i can't imagine that it
came
everything came just naturally and off
the bat you must have improved along the
way what how do you systematically
improve as a marketer what do you hold
yourself accountable to is it project by
project do you debrief
with with different with different
clients in different positions how do
you get better yourself and what you do
experience i mean it's the same way you
get better at asking questions in
interviews you ask questions you see how
the other people have answered it to the
answer well maybe you weren't precise in
your speech so you you sharpen your saw
and try to improve your questions and
how you ask and when you space maybe i
should chop this question up into two
questions and so you always improve
you're improving by experience and by
getting that feedback loop that's how
the same thing i do and every other
professional improves is that i testing
did it work did those leads become
opportunities did they end up speaking
to sales or they just filled out a form
and they're ignoring us forever so these
are things that i need to learn and see
i need to incorporate i look back at the
messaging at the targeting and all of
that who else is seeing the other
content within their organization and
you just continue to improve and adapt
and you look at the data use a little
bit of intuition and uh some humility
goes a long way
i want to look back on on what you said
before but it left me thinking
about the
the way that you're optimizing for this
trust and for optimizing for the message
to be delivered by a person who you have
faith in right and therefore it sounds
to me like if in traditional marketing i
was taught that i can either optimize
for impressions or clicks and probably
some balance of the two and i'm paying
for a combination of them what you're
saying is i don't really care about the
impression when when the person gets the
impression they will click on it because
i'm making sure that it's so critical
that i that i hit the nail on the head
right is that is that sort of the
strategy here i mean that's just if your
job is to get if your goal is to get a
click sure but what good is the click it
was click bait right to get to something
that they didn't weren't looking for to
begin with at the end of the day you
need to speak to people's pain points
and challenges and speak as technical as
possible if you're targeting cyber
security professionals or any kind of
technical people because if you speak
their language and then there's a bigger
pain point they're more likely to click
but more importantly turns out if
they're not interested and they're not
in the market if you're too generic they
might click and then it might not be
relevant to begin with so you want to be
as technical and as specific as possible
so those that aren't in the market opt
out and ignore your ad don't click on it
and you don't pay for that click
right if we're looking at marketing the
next three four years and you're in your
opinion
let's stick with cyber security
marketing and obviously you know some
people call it a bubble it doesn't
really matter for the sake of this
conversation even though i believe it's
not and i i trusted a post about that
last week by the way i don't know if you
saw did you see it i'm gonna be i'm
gonna be spending the next half hour
reading that post yeah it's not that
long it's about i think it's a wave not
a bubble
we're catching up we're closing the gap
on the cyber security vulnerabilities
and that's why so i think things will
slow down but i don't think the bubble's
gonna pop
so i think that you and i are gonna have
an interesting conversation regardless
after this episode uh but
what's gonna how do you see the world of
cyber security marketing transitioning
in the next few years it's just gonna
grow and adapt more and and that's it
being able to reach them i think
influencer marketing is going to grow
bigger uh a bigger piece of the pie
going on because it's about trust
you know
it's just it's about trust it's about
trust like i mean right if you try to
tell me if you send me a workout plan or
with ads do this do that you know get
your abs like this here's some before
and after photos use this
but guess what my personal trainer comes
twice every sunday morning and every
thursday morning my wife and i work out
together and he helps us if he
recommends thing i'm doing it he's the
person i trust so you got to get to him
to get to me which is why sometimes you
think you want to get to the seats that
you don't who do they trust who do they
advise including people in their
organization and influencers without and
also what their competitors are doing
and so on and so forth so it's all about
building trust need to build trust with
people individuals organizations
influencers and through that you can use
your marketing channels you can use
different channels within marketing in
order to reach and get the message out
to the right people so therefore you can
reach the end person you are trying to
and the people around them so therefore
they'll move forward we're trying to
learn more about your product or in or
my clients products
i love it well
how do you
do what you do where do you what do you
is it is it fun
is it the the thrill of of getting it
right
how do you work so hard with you because
obviously i don't think you come to
these understandings in this and and the
motivation that you're presenting here
just by holding a regular 95 job uh well
i don't know who's holding a nine to
five job i mean if you're working nine
to five and there's a mistake um i'm
just i'm passionate and i have an insane
level of professionalism and i will not
let myself do anything half-ass so
anything i do it's hardcore so
i'm go all in when i work out it's all
in you know what i mean when i sleep i
make sure i get the best sleep and heavy
sleep and deep sleep and uninterrupted
sleep whatever everything i do i go all
it you know i mean i'm there i'm active
and i want to be the best and i want to
dominate and that is my goal so i that's
it i keep trying to be the best and
if not life isn't worth living you know
at 50
this is one of my favorite moments in
over 700 episodes well thank you very
very much for for the these last 20
minutes i really appreciate your time
and and this amazing energy i'm leaving
more energy than when i came in with and
i learned a lot so thank you very much
and stay safe and stay healthy pleasure
[Music]
you